celle dernière visite et le 4 juillet
nous allons remettre les clés aux
entreprises qui on veut devenir maître
des lieux
c'est à dire que eelv ont commencé à
démolir cet après midi il y avait comme
un parfum d'adieu dans le sillage du
maire de besançon
une armée de journalistes les derniers
curieux d'un site mille fois visité
premier arrêt dans cette grande salle où
trônaient les machines à filer le nylon
à l'époque on disait le terreau galles
la raison d'être de la rodia pierre
grand père un fût d'ouvriers ici pendant
vingt ans j'ai les clés de toutes les
usines avec les passe partout et nabeul
et passe partout
comme il était et ça me permettait
d'aller intervenir dans toutes les
ateliers d'aller chercher du matériel
éventuellement pour remplacer quelque
chose défectueux la rodia le lieu de
toutes les histoires économique
politique et plus tard artistique
ici les graffeurs ont rhabillé les murs
pendant 30 ans comme d'autres julien
bost pierrot il ya fait ses armes
et si c'est le dernier lui en fait qui
reste de toute cette l'époque sa grande
époque des années 90 des grands terrains
des grandes usines bisontine c'est à la
fois un endroit d'expression
d'apprentissage est aussi un lieu de
pèlerinage on est regardé les nouveaux
styles un sociologue a recensé près de
600 fresque dans la rodia une
concentration exceptionnelle
il a été envisagé de démonter certaines
parties de lusine comme des portes par
exemple des panneaux qui comporte des
fresques qu'on peut juger intéressantes
sur les toits on prend la mesure des
cinquante cinq mille mètres carrés de
lusine les urbanistes ne garderons que
5000 mètres carrés soit 10% des
bâtiments le chantier de démolition va
durer deux ans après tous les rêves sont
possibles 50 espaces de jeux de prairies
selon lequel y aura des activités
sportives culturelles
ce qui fera de besançon une capitale
française du sport outdoor mots j'aime
me dire le sport santé le sport nature
les véritables travaux débuteront en
une nouvelle vie commencera alors aulas
rhodia